gracias por caminar en la pantalla de
france 24 estamos de regreso para
actualizar las principales noticias en
materia económica junto a nuestra
compañera daniela hablando vamos a
comenzar en américa latina' vamos a
venezuela que ya lleva siete años de
contracción económica verdad y santiago
mire hay un estudio del ces la que es el
círculo de estudios latinoamericanos que
señala que la contracción venezolana del
30 por ciento en 2020 no sólo fue más
severa la más severa de la región
también fue la más dura contracción
anual a lo largo de una profunda
depresión que suma siete años
ininterrumpidos de retroceso productivo
el informe recoge cifras del fondo
monetario internacional según las cuales
venezuela era el año pasado el país con
mayor tasa de desempleo del mundo con
más del 58 por ciento y pronostica que
esa situación se va a mantener durante
2021 pero lo más preocupante no es tanto
el desempleo como la informalidad que
alcanza a casi la mitad de los
trabajadores en lo que si está cediendo
la nación petrolera al parecer es en la
inflación aunque la cifra no al cerro
en un tres mil por ciento en el primer
semestre de este año se desaceleró según
ses la bueno y en medio de la pandemia
buenas noticias para chile y para toda
la región de américa latina porque si
novak va a producir vacunas en este país
sudamericano verdad claro que sí el
laboratorio chino anunció que tendrá una
capacidad de producción de alrededor de
60 millones de vacunas coronaba al año
que también serán exportadas a otros
países de latinoamérica la idea es que
comience a funcionar en el primer
semestre de 2022 y no solamente con
biológicos contra el cubil 19 sino
contra la gripe y la hepatitis chile
inició su producción nacional en el año
mil 867 y hace 18 o 19 años atrás
perdimos esa posibilidad digo que es un
día feliz para chile pero no solamente
para chile porque una vez que la fábrica
produzca vacunas acá
se van a poder exportar a latinoamérica
aquellos países que han tenido
dificultades para adquirir vacunas bueno
otra noticia vinculada a la pandemia
pero que no va a tener repercusiones tan
importantes obviamente porque van a
lanzar una nueva barbie vinculada a la
pandemia de la barby que faltaba claro
que si santiago mire la desarrolladora
británica de vacunas será gilbert tiene
muchos elogios científicos pero ahora
tiene uno bastante particular y es que
el gigante fabricante de juguetes mattel
lanzó una línea de muñecas llamada
modelo a seguir lo que hizo fue crear
una barbilla imagen y semejanza de
gilbert quien la lee de quién es la
líder del equipo que creó la vacuna
contra kobe 19 de oxford días atrás
erika y también de cinco de sus colegas
entre ellas una enfermera que trató al
primer paciente de kobe 19 en brooklyn
también la latina o droid cruz una
doctora de primera línea que a su vez es
activista contra la discriminación en lo
invito a que escuchemos aa la doctora
es un concepto muy extraño tener una
muñeca barbie creada a mi semejanza
espero que sea más normal que las niñas
piensen en carreras científicas aunque
para ser honesta cuando era niña nunca
creí que tendría una carrera científica
santiago y es que tener barbie propia no
es un lujo que se han dado muchas
personas entre ellas están beyonce y
marilyn monroe como le pareció
absolutamente ya llegaron las
periodistas de aquí estemos atentos ver
si llega la tuya hablemos ahora de uber
que volvió las ganancias
bueno la multinacional estadounidense de
transporte reportó este miércoles que
tuvo ganancias por mil 36 millones de
dólares entre enero y junio de 2021 esto
supone un cambio radical de tendencia
frente al mismo período del año pasado
cuando en el peor momento de la pandemia
tuvo pérdidas por 4 mil 700 millones de
dólares para nadie es un secreto
santiago que la empresa con sede en san
francisco california se está
beneficiando ampliamente del fin de las
restricciones a la movilidad impuestas
en varias partes del mundo para contener
la propagación del comit 19 y lo dejó en
cifras los trayectos contratados se
dispararon en 184 por ciento
en estos seis primeros meses lo
beneficiado con la pandemia sin lugar a
dudas indicadores de la jornada que
dicen wall street' del cerro mixto tras
conocerse que el sector privado de eeuu
agregó a penas 330 mil puestos de
trabajo en julio un dato peor del
esperado y en américa latina' cuarta
jornada consecutiva en rojo para la
bolsa de buenos aires cerramos como
siempre con la cifra del día cuales 370
millones de dólares a propósito de un
año de la explosión en beirut este
miércoles una conferencia internacional
liderada por francia recaudó ese monto
en ayudas para invertir en los próximos
12 meses la ciudadanía por esta
completísima crónica económica en
nuestra audiencia siguen informando se
en france 24 y en france 24 punto com
[Música]